you introduced a new mascot Chuck the
Condor I think we have a photo here of
Chuck the condor Chuck good-looking
that's it yeah how do you feel
chuck is doing because you're an
energetic guy and you ever think you
would want a very energetic mascot has
Chuck the Condor working out for you
Chuck's off to a good start
now the the high bar excellence of
excellence is the coyote in San Antonio
when the coyote says yell boom people
yell when the coyote says cheer they
cheer oh so maybe they're doing it out
of fear maybe it's not like a fun thing
I don't care why I just want it no Z in
the darn building I think we have it
you're saying this coyote right here
you think he here oh yeah the coyote
dressed like Michael Jackson is your
hero
absolutely okay and because he really
gets the crowd going boom okay have you
ever thought of just buying that coyote
and stealing him and bringing him you
could do that we could I guess yeah we
then have him fire hot dogs and chili
into the crowd and then you've got
frankly just a mess
now you also uh I'm told that you're
that you slam dunk I haven't seen the
footage but you slam dunked off a
trampoline now that's it that's kind of
dangerous right I was worried about it
yeah I did it who came to you with this
idea that's some of the folks in Clipper
staff we're getting ready to launch
Chuck and we needed Chuck to get some
attention we gave out 19,000 pairs of
Chuck Taylor but it just didn't seem
enough for they to launch our mascot she
said why don't you try to dunk the ball
right and I said okay you know I'm
afraid of trampolines yeah she talked me
a [ __ ] talked me into it and then
finally I said
you should come out but don't touch me I
want to know your medical history I'm so
scared of you right now you're an insane
person I think we have footage of you
assistant right
[Applause]
you wanna try try what will get you out
in staples any clipper game you want to
oh I could slam dunk
you could slam dunk for you won't need a
trampoline trampoline
I'll need wires a crane
I gotta lower the rim does need a fee oh
the rim to four feet nice walk over and
drop it in and I want to be holding a
martini the whole time
you